[Musique]
j'ai trouvé un sac à main qui appartient
à une certaine greta idec dieu vous
bénisse je me suis levé vous trouvez
dans les métros au jeu vous offre une
tasse de café vous est si gentille c'est
pas pour devise est je suis seul depuis
le départ de ma fille je tombe bien
alors la mère n'arrêtait pas dire que
j'étais comme du chewing gum un vrai pot
d'accueil
les bougies qu'est ce que vous les avez
trouvés
je pense qu'elle sème des sacs dans tous
les coins de la ville en espérant qu'on
les lui rapportera ce que tu as fait on
du sel on laisse j'ai vu les autres sacs
greta je ne veux plus jamais vous revoir
ne sait vraiment quitté
ne trouvez pas à diviser la voie
publique on peut pas intervenir
et ça
comme c'est amusant
bonsoir je m'appelle française je serai
votre service
on a c'est pas possible non mais vous
êtes une enfance étoiles enfant tu as
besoin d'une mère puis vous interdit de
parler de ma mère c'est pourquoi cette
rencontre
c'est une grande malade peut garder la
balle et rongé par le chagrin et les
morts
tout le monde a besoin d'une amie et on
est plus que des amis
on n'a rien
il ya quelque chose que tu dois savoir
sur greta quoi vous n'êtes pas qu'est ce
que vous avez fait
essayez donc de vous débarrasser de
crète
[Musique]